I actually really like the export page
mine's got like fighting and
bodybuilding so I prefer to follow
comedy but when it goes to explore page
comedy is harder to click on because the
other two are so much more visual if
there's just a dude with a mic I'm like
I don't know if it's gonna be funny but
I do know this guy's jacked it would be
interesting if images make a comeback I
will say this when I look at someone's
profile I actually go only for the
images because I don't feel like
watching videos like if I pull anyone up
I immediately go to images I'll keep
scrolling until I find an image and then
I'll go click it it just feels more
chill